stuff Lamb with spinach and pine nuts
this meats are perfect for special
occasions they look impressive taste
amazing but more importantly they are so
simple to do
pan on for the stuffing it's a saddle of
lamb basically a sort of Rolls-Royce cut
perfectly shaped and it suits stuffing
it's an absolute tea but the stuffing
finely chop an onion
garlic
nice thin slices
oil in
onions and garlic in
[Music]
salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
Juicy seasoned so it helps to season the
inside of the Lamb
now we've got a color on those onions
we're going to throw in some pine nuts
and that helps to give a bit of a
texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in
and just lay the spinach over the pine
nuts
it looks like a lot of spinach that's
going to condense and disappear almost
instantly
[Music]
just more flavor and spinach when you
saute it as opposed to steaming it or
boiling it gas off and look at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
breadcrumbs crumpled feta over the
spinach feta cheese adds a beautifully
salty sharp and creamy flavor
and what this does
it brings that stuffing together
now
open up the lamb keep those little
fillets to the side that's the channel
that we want to stuff so I want to just
open that up a little bit there
salt and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in
we're going to season it with sumo sumac
is a wonderful lemony spice that goes
brilliantly with lamb and you can get it
in most big supermarkets and I sort of
cuts through that thick Rich sweetness
of the Lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon if you're preparing this
for the day ahead then let the stuffing
cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it someone's going to
squeeze out so load up the ends
take these Beauties these little fillets
and just support that stuffing and sort
of increase that beautiful tunnel and
then from there
over
there
and bring that towards you and then roll
like I said some of the stuff is going
to come out
now just tie it first off around the
side and don't worry about some flash
which is not just tie it
one in the middle
you can get butcher string from your
local butcher or at cookware shops I got
two ties
go too tight it just forces all that
stuffing out of the Lamb when it's in
the oven
nice now I want to season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but get your tray onto the
gas oil in
get it really nicely colored
none of your stuffing is coming out of
the sides really important
look at that color beautiful does
Kickstart a roasting process
gas off into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly and means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices next I'm making a
simple but sophisticated accompaniment
for the lamb top and tell the Cucumber
peel it
cut the Cucumber into three and just
core
taking out all that it's just sort of
watery seedium it spoils the flavor
sliced the Cucumber
cucumber in
really nice way of making a cheap and
cheerful cucumber look glamorous we're
going to dress that cucumber with a nice
fresh yogurt a couple of tablespoons
next some fresh mint dressing Touch of
salt
Touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses
that just sweetens it up finish that
with lemon
mix that up
lamb is rested
carefully take off the string and then
just gently pull them back straight As
edge knife that's going to cut through
that crispy fat on the outside instantly
I tied it purposely so I can get
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly look at your line
where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing
lay and down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing Meats
is for special occasions because that is
a saddle of lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor Dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
Feast here are three more of my favorite
easy stuff dishes that are perfect for
any Feast
first up chicken with garlic and
Chestnut stuffing packed with flavor and
earthy richness
[Music]
for the stuffing before I finely chopped
onion garlic
celery and hot olive oil
next add pine nuts which have a lovely
creamy taste and chopped earthy cooked
chestnuts both add a wonderfully chewy
texture and richness to stuffings
season
and add chopped parsley
[Music]
then stirring cooked wild rice
next take a whole deboned chicken it's
fiddly to do at home but if you ask your
butcher will do it for you and pile the
stuffing mixture along the center now
simply roll the chicken up tightly and
tie it with your butcher string
then roast in a hot oven for just over
an hour
[Music]
and be careful magnificent thick slices
so impressive so easy and trust me this
is a dish guaranteed to get a fantastic
reaction on any occasion
my next recipe is an old classic roast
chicken but with a simple twist it takes
on a new life and is guaranteed to
impress
one of the things I love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove is that there's always
something new to learn every day new
ingredients new techniques and new
cuisines
start off with the stuffing
it's amazing how exciting a stuffed
roast chicken can be because it keeps
the chicken incredibly moist and gives a
delicious texture inside the bird I'm
going to start off with cured chorizo
this is a traditional Spanish sausage
and it's
garlicky spicy incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing get that
chorizo in
start cooking that down and get all
those oils out
a little touch of olive oil in there to
get it going right onions
chopped
add the onions to the chorizo and in a
matter of seconds they'll change color
as they soak up all the flavor that
lovely spiciness has been stolen from
that sausage and now the onions smell
incredible
garlic
garlic in fresh thyme just hold it down
and put your fingers on there and it's a
really nice way of taking off all those
nice fragrant little time flowers
you can hear it cracking in the
background
these are cannellini beans they're waxy
very soft and so delicious but very
dense but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down drain them off in
they're going to take on all that juice
as well from this threesome I'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some help
and that looks like it's a dish on its
own good enough to eat now I want to
sweeten things up a little bit
Tomatoes half dried
thin
that sweetens up
the stuffing
beautiful
the stuffing's ready look at the color
everything
of Spanish it looks delicious now
stuffing the chicken I like taking off
these little knuckles
as the chicken Cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum and take off those little wing tips
as well
salt pepper
so important
now you're stuffing I want to go right
inside the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're pushing
out all the empty spaces in the carcass
and take a nice large Lemon push the
lemon in
pick up the parcel's nose pull the skin
over olive oil on top
sauce
pepper
a teaspoon of paprika sprinkle it on and
then get your hands
sort of rub that head let's see what the
paprika's doing to the chicken putting
this like sweet spicy marinade it's not
even roasted yet but it looks delicious
400 mL of white wine same quantity of
water that helps the chicken to steam
Chicken in
be generous with the time Sprigs
[Music]
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy
into the oven
[Music]
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on nice take it out and remove the
full lid then give it another 30 minutes
to crisp up that skin
look at that
it's so important to make sure you take
that tinfoil off with half an hour to go
beautiful
Pierce that open so squeeze it in that
delicious gravy mix that into the tray
save that
that's really nice fragrant lemony
spiced roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible I'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day
and then just get your chicken roasting
juices
now
cut the chicken up
hold the drum
and slice straight through
and there's that wonderful drum and the
thigh through the wishbone
off
slice with the point at an angle so you
can see the texture of that amazing
roast chicken
take my cooking juices that's what I
give a really nice sort of lemony flavor
over my chicken and there you go
are delicious very Charming stuffed
roast chicken
[Music]